are your thoughts on if playing college
football in empty stadiums is something
that you see as part of the equation in
the fall
yeah it is not for me
i don't know how we reopen our campuses
put students back in dorms and in dining
halls
and
then say
we can't be in a football stadium
together i i
that doesn't feel
compatible to me i'm not sure how you
say we're okay with the students
engaging on the field but not fans in
the stands
now might there be approaches to fans in
the stands that are a little different
that help ensure safety
absolutely but i can't see playing at
empty stadiums
notre dame athletic director jack
swarbrick yesterday lunch talk live with
mike tarico and chris that has been the
overriding point that i've tried to make
as it relates to college football you
can't have the football without the
college you can't justify the disconnect
between the campuses remain closed to
any classes or other in-person events
but we're going to go ahead and play
football in empty stadiums because we
want to make the money that comes from
the football they understand they cannot
do that you can't have the football
without the college so no games until
you can open the campuses and have some
collection of individuals in the stadium
you may have people spread out it may
look very strange on tv a checkerboard
pattern we've talked about that
possibility in the past that may be what
it takes but the idea of college
football in empty stadiums that's not
happening nfl
if they have to they will college
they're not going to do it without fans
no i mean you know to what you're saying
mike how can they i mean it's first off
it's scholastic first right i mean they
re they're
they're coming dangerously close to
exposing themselves here you know with
some of this conversation i've heard
over the last week about
you know what what do you want to say
what no no i've just you said they're
coming dangerously close to exposing
themselves and i'm just thinking that
well that could be taken a lot of
different ways it could be you're right
i mean get your mind out of the gutter
okay let's just get back on football
here okay but either way they are coming
dangerously close to exposing themselves
to showing that it's all about the money
and the dollars to what you're saying
okay
all right mr uh nudie guy over there all
right
you know
you know and then i have
hello london we're back maybe but then
you get into you know uh my man jack
swarbrick over there at notre dame he
understands that you know notre dame is
a one of the finest institutions in our
country they're not going to play sports
if the kids aren't in school they are a
school and scholastics you know they're
they're education first there and also
you know the college football part of it
is the pageantry of the band and all the
fans and you know the the school pride
and everything about that it's different
than the nfl that way to where yes i
don't think it would be as a fun a game
to watch without fans so yeah if
school's not back in session i mean i
i'm with uh jack there's no way you
could play college football and a lot
more moving parts in college football to
make it happen than there is in the nfl
and the the other side of the coin is
this
everybody knows at this point that the
student athletes are more athlete than
student and i understand at some
institutions
that's not quite the same and notre dame
is one that still maintains very high
athletic standards for anyone who gets
in so and and they've maybe suffered for
it on on the field over the years
definitely but right but um but most of
us get it that college football is a
gigantic money maker for these colleges
and if you take the cash out of the
equation that comes from the tv deals
you're going to wreak havoc on a
college's budget i get that i understand
that
and we all know that and it's almost
like
when when wrestling finally acknowledged
to the world that it's fake nothing
really changed like i don't know how big
of a deal it would be
for college football to finally admit to
us what we already know
and and and do whatever they have to do
to play those games even if the campuses
aren't open again i'm not saying that
they shouldn't chris i'm saying this
yeah i got you if it if it entails
if if the only barrier
is letting us all know what we already
know who cares go ahead and do it i
guess that's kind of how i'm looking at
it because there is a financial benefit
to playing games getting the money on
the books and helping the budgets from
imploding at colleges throughout the
country
well you know then they're opening that
box with my friend pandora in there okay
for everybody to use the argument once
again
okay of like they're not just these are
not just uh you know uh
these are professionals they need to be
paid money i'm losing my track of
thought or my words there but but but
you're going to be compensated would ar
it would bolster the argument for the
the scholar athlete to say see here you
go we should be being paid some more
money to account for what we're doing
for this school financially
i think you're right it's so tenuous
right now and we see the fire flare up
from time to time whether it's a union
drive at northwestern or just public
pressure that periodically is placed on
the schools the push for the name image
and likeness laws in various states i
feel like at this point
college football is just trying to hold
off the reckoning as long as possible
and playing these games with no campuses
open with no fans in the stand could be
the tipping point where once the dust
finally settles you've got everything
you need to make the argument that these
kids need to be paid and i personally
believe they need to be paid everybody
else connected to the sport is getting
paid from the president of the
university down to the guy or the gal
selling popcorn in the stadium everybody
is getting paid except the people on the
field and you're right that's well
that's why they're clinging to this even
though we all know just show you how
tenuous it is we all know
we all know the disconnect and we're
fine with it for the most part but the
moment you admit it is the moment you
end up putting yourself in a position
where you got to start cutting checks to
these play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports